folks joe derosa here from the taste
buds podcast
you want to see me on the road come see
me i will be in austin texas at the
creek and cave may 22 20th and 21st
that's four shows only
i'm gonna be
doing more dates coming up soon
unfortunately i had to cancel my west
coast dates so i will not be performing
in irvine california or in san diego now
as i was supposed to in april but come
see me
in may at the creek and cave in austin i
promise i will make up those west coast
dates as soon as humanly possible and if
you are in the new york area come to
jelly roses at 174 rivington street
we are open tuesday through sunday get a
drink get a sandwich get both have a
good time uh if you want to know about
my show dates go to joe derosainfo.com
if you want to know about joey rose's
info you go to
joeyrosesnyc.com i hope that's not too
confusing at joderosa on instagram and
twitter
i'm talking to you directly
i'm coming on tour and i don't always do
it so you got to come see me and here we
go april 15th and 16th i will be in
louisville and evansville april 23rd and
24th i will be in tulsa and oklahoma
city beacon theater new york city first
time may 14th there's going to be some
surprise guests there and that's all i
can say but you do not want to miss that
and i'm going out west cali i'm finally
coming to you i'm going to be in san
diego on may 21st and at the wilton
theater in los angeles for the first
time ever on may 22nd everything is
available right now at savolcano
comedy.com a little bit taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to the mic i'm talking
taste buds
cheers
thank you for having me
welcome
[Music]
we're off to the races today
in honor of the oscars ceremony yeah
in memoriam of our careers
in memoriam of the tradition of the
oscars
finally coming to an end
and the craziest
thing i've ever seen transpire online
ever
ever i couldn't do anything after that
by the way my mom was over and we put on
we just rented licorice pizza and i i
bought it for 19.99 a second wait nice
should you say you and your mom rented
licorice pizza together yeah but she
came over dinner and we were choosing
between four movies candy man licorice
pizza uh summer of soul and the worst
person in the world and i i texted some
friends and they said go with licorice
pizza that is
19.99 it's seven minutes into the movie
my phone starts busting everyone's like
was that real was that real happening
and they say what happened i'm like what
do you get i pause licker's pizza i go
over to the thing i was taping it
because just in case something like this
happened i rewound watch it we never
watched liquor's pizza again i rewound
it a hundred times my mom just sat in
the corner while i s well i texted you
but can we
really that's a movie about a 15 year
old 25 year old
yeah yeah and you thought the slap was
inappropriate
listen
but that's an odd list of movies to
watch with your mom well i wasn't
thinking of my mom i was thinking of
what movies would i want to see well it
sounds like you googled movies that have
food in them you know like candy candy
man
always on the mind
today we are battling obviously will
smith versus chris rock i am team will
smith
pat i mean pat sorry
sal excuse me that's my other podcast
sal is team chris rock and we have the
great bert crusher here as a first ever
on taste buds not just a guest a
mediator of the battle he is going up
the middle right to
afraid to choose a side
let's be honest listen i got a movie
coming out the machine and i might need
some help from both of these guys i got
news for you your boy mark campbell had
a few things to say on twitter about it
are you serious
oh my god
he plays my dad in the movie and this
mother
he always has a take on everything i'm
like
shut up
mark hamill is is look that's what i
love about the guy is he has a hot take
on everything he has no he does not have
a problem biting his tongue i admire
that about him no i bite my tongue he's
great constantly he's great but i mean
you think he's going to protect you he's
[ __ ] on star wars in the star wars
interviews like
him do this
he will trash me up and down when they
go what was it like working with burt
and he's like you mean that bloated
alcohol
somebody who would change lines at the
drop of a hat and never learn his lines
he yeah dude he was when they
interviewed him for last jedi he was on
like morning tv during press and they're
like
he goes he literally goes he goes well
you know i think the line in the trailer
says it best uh this is not going to go
how you think it is
and everybody in lucasfilm was like dude
what are you doing stop
[ __ ] you gotta love that though that
not to really not give a [ __ ]
yeah i wish i i wish i could be that i
could give a lot
yeah at this point my life would give a
lot of i think
well he's not losing work from it from
speaking his mind not mark hamill he's
mark hamill you want mark hamill you get
mark he's got him he's gotta well i mean
you think it is kind of like the
irishman where you're like
they're they're never gonna whack star
wars never going to whack mart hamilton
they did they killed luke skywalker
[ __ ] i haven't seen that episode
what are you talking about
in the last jedi yeah he dies
he does
mark luke skywalker dies i know you're
[ __ ] with me stop no i watched you
yes no you're [ __ ] what are you
talking about what's the thing you do
you mean he didn't die you stayed in the
mountains whatever guys at the end from
force projecting
what wait hold on that was clear
ambiguous
well he shows up as a ghost in the third
movie i think it's pretty goddamn clear
oh okay yeah let's just call him and
find out oh my god wait stop it wait a
minute tattooed on my arm don't don't
tease me like this bert let me see if i
got
i'm gonna bring up some of his uh some
of his other movies from the 80s listen
to me
yes but when he's when he when he's a
ghost he's young
what are you talking about when he's a
ghost in jedi i mean sorry when he's a
ghost oh no force projecting oh okay
okay wait what
no he dies from force projection i
watched it why didn't i take why wasn't
my takeaway that he died
did he die is it amazing you gotta be
honest i don't know what's going on
[ __ ] nerd i don't watch him like oh
look at that
my point is i said it was but this was
the joke i was trying to make was that
you go well mark hamill can say whatever
he wants about star wars because they're
never going to whack luke skywalker and
then they do and then it made me think
of the irishman when joe pesci goes
if they can whack a president they can
whack a president of a union would they
would
we could kill you you know
[Laughter]
anyway i love the guy if if what did he
say what did he say last night i mean i
don't know i might oh he's great as a
joker's voice too isn't he yeah he's the
best joker of all time i've never funny
i've never seen that joker i was i aged
out of that yeah so i only know him as
luke skywalker that's the guy right
there he said he puts on his goddamn
he puts on his what do you call his
underoos hold on hold on right before he
goes to bed he said do you think what he
said is worse or better than what tom
zuguru said i don't know what either of
them said okay you read i don't know
mark hamill and i'll read thomas mark
campbell didn't say anything bad i'm
just saying he definitely had
a take on it that's awesome it was
definitely like a will smith shouldn't
have done that tape okay this is which
is obvious we're gonna discuss this the
the battle though is is going to not be
about who is right and wrong at the
awards the battle is going to be if you
only had to take one of them for the
rest of your life to entertain you you
can only choose one who which
entertainer are you taking and it's
gonna be based on solely that not the
awards we're just using their names for
clickbait yeah exactly and then look at
this they snubbed saggit in the uh
i think he goes next year though right
because he was this is that tragedy
happened this year that's what i heard
so do me a favor and read what tom
segura wrote about about
okay this is at tom segura
right 1 33 p.m [ __ ] will smith's candy
ass smacking a dude four inches shorter
and 50 pounds lighter okay don't
necessarily disagree he's just in his
feelings because his bald-headed well i
don't know if i should really be saying
this because if if someone just clips
the front then i'm saying it but anyway
no it's a band he's just you know it's a
bad sign when he hands you the phone to
read it
just say it
he's just in his feelings because his
bald-headed
[ __ ] been [ __ ] around on him for
years and he takes it we all know who he
wishes he could slap
hashtag [ __ ] will wow
so sugar's on the fence yes the gory's
on the fence shagora is being a little a
little bit ambiguous
i just i just by the way this is my
business partner okay right right like
we have a movie in the works like what
the [ __ ] are you doing right
so i feel like yeah but yeah
yeah you don't want to go against i mean
that's that's that's that's a very
public statement he's got a guy who has
a big reach i would say that is a hot
take
uh okay this is what this is what uh
mark hamill said it's not a hot take
yeah was the comics are very adept at
handling heckler's violent physical
assault not so much
good job mark yeah dad thank you yeah
yeah
oh but then this was the hashtag that
made me earlier when you said i'm
staying out of this oh so how this was
the hashtag that made this stick in my
head ugliest oscar moment ever which he
is right
no i actually saw a retort to that of
the person that listed like 10 things
that were horrific
you know other than a slap
i just love that and i can't stop
talking about this today
i can't but it's so funny to me that
hollywood was demanding that the
ukrainian president be invited to the
ceremony so we could stand with them in
like civilized solidarity
and then this is what happens at this is
the event it would be like if you had
like
you know your wedding
at your wedding two two of the groomsmen
got into a fight or something you know
what i mean it's just so embarrassing if
i'm on the street and chris rock comes
up to you makes a joke about my wife
who has a condition i'm going to slap
chris rock
if in the context of the awards he's a
comedian that rift a joke that may not
have known about her condition that also
by the way jada i think was online
saying like you know what i got a human
all you can do is laugh i'm going to
shave my head i you know it's no big
deal i accept it you know ollie's b he
was like i love you can't wait to see
you in in g.i jean three it's almost
just like she shaved her head you shaved
your head you're a bad you're a badass
you could be in that it was almost like
borderline of like was it supposed to be
an insult to her i don't i don't know if
it was i think it was just a dumb joke
like you shaved your head yeah but then
laughing it was yeah it was a crazy
outdated first of all if we're going to
get an apology from chris rock i wanted
to be over there jennifer osmosis jones
listen anyway folks catch me in
austin next month no apology coming from
chris
i want to know what demi moore has to
say about everything that's what i want
to know
and the army but also too this is what
kills me it's like
this is and i'm team will smith
let's establish this team will smith
versus team chris ross correct and i
will angels advocate and devil's
advocate throughout this entire process
but what about angels in america and
what is your take on the age of christ i
saw angels in america and it really
opened my eyes to the pandemic
[Laughter]
i mean i watched angels in the outfield
aids it was about age oh never mind
i can't even tell if you're joking
i don't even know what it is
i've known you long enough i wouldn't be
surprised if you sat through all the
angels in america and were like wait
that wasn't about corona i would not be
one bit surprised if you didn't know
they're gay
i didn't get that
this is what happened you're on right
now when you start the hashtag oscar's
so white no
[Laughter]
no one's using that headset today
no one at all
all right we're even we got him
yeah but here's the thing normally by
the way normally we talk about how we
don't drink a lot yeah and we try to
hide it on the podcast
especially him but you're here and we
let off with a shot and we have a bottle
of water hold on i love it i talk every
week about how i drink too much yeah you
say you don't want a podcast we're not
we don't really like like outwardly
drink no no but but
we are time we get to next week's
episode no no the way we drink on the
podcast usually like like an alcoholic
secretary like a bottle kind of hidden
in the bottom
is when you drink by yourself and no one
knows it and you're hiding it that is
the best way to drink this is gonna
sound this is gonna sound like i am have
a problem i don't but i you just jog my
memory one time and when i was working
in an office in prudential securities
one of these guys john he tells you one
day you know what i do he goes i have a
bottle of captain morgan in my locked
drawer and then on fridays i just make
cocktails back here and drink them all
the time and then i was like my mind was
blown and then i started doing that oh i
would drink in the office at work on
friday granted i was 22 23 years old
yeah my friend college yeah i'm friends
with nine to fives it'll be like bro
i've been hitting it to kill all day at
work that's well i did it occasionally
you know that they're like they're like
[ __ ] it all dude what does any of this
even mean anymore people are at the end
of the rope dude yeah
people at the end of their tethers yeah
i could drink like that i can't drink
like that like i can't i can't just what
do you mean like i can't i can't like um
like i like secret drinking like i can't
if i have responsibility if i have like
anything responsible to do work anything
family like that i can't do it but like
i like secret drinking at airports when
like like this girl introduced me to
water bottling where you fill it up with
like sprite and soda and then or soda
and tito's yeah and walk through the
airport with a water bottle oh yeah like
dude dude how about why do you need to
do that
i want your past security but once
you're oh because you're saying you
can't take the drink from the bar at the
end oh yeah you can't walk it big so you
go on that one
you get the [ __ ] the the thermos and
then you go yeah i'll just take one more
and then you dump it you go i went down
fast i'll take one more and then dump it
and then walk around the plane those are
the [ __ ]
part
i got a great airport drinking story
wait this is what i was going really
quick just about the oscars let me do
let me do a one-two here what i was
gonna say is is what's funny to me is
this is the ceremony that two years ago
will smith said i'm boycotting this
f the academy it's racist
blah blah xyz right
then you go to the thing
you got a guy on stage who's only ever
hired in the way that ricky gervais has
hired it's like
he's the guy that's going to come out
and do insult jokes yeah and then you
get mad and then you cry about the honor
of winning and i know he said it wasn't
about the award but still it was an
emotional moment i don't and this is not
a shot at him specifically it's a shot
at at
the entire scene i don't understand why
people expect more out of the academy
like i don't understand why you would go
there and think this is going to be
something that i ethically find sound
it's not it's never going to be the
academy no but above that look okay
right you could be on chris rock's side
you'd be on wilson oh he's talked about
his wife slap the [ __ ] out of him he's a
cop he's a comic that was headline
whatever it is but it just is odd that
we can't agree on paper it was a assault
i was laughing with my friend today that
i go i go
he clearly my buddy goes she goes he hit
her
that's where he smacks jada and i go he
hit he slaps like a man who knows how to
slap like like did not leave a mark
i i watched it a million times it's wild
first of all you can't take a hit better
than chris rock dude it's hands behind
you
here's the argument that was had our bus
driver said uh
i know no real man is it gonna isn't
gonna um
if you start walking to me i'm gonna put
my hands up that's what's so beautiful
is chris rock really he didn't know what
he did anything he had his hands behind
his back he wasn't expecting it because
it was will smith the odds nobody's
expecting the fresh prince to hit you he
said if it was russell crowe marching up
chris rock would have been like
you know what i mean i mean you could
have a better luck getting hit by
lightning than chris rock thinking in
that moment he was coming to hit him he
probably thought he's gonna he's digging
into the joke even when he's walking up
he's like oh here comes king richard and
he's laughing and if you notice will
smith he he actually stays if you really
watch because i watch this thing like i
was watching tape and i was [ __ ]
mike thomas it's a brutal film yeah he
waits till the very last second and then
he he just whips it like so is that it's
unexpected he knows how to fight you can
tell will smith knows how to fight what
if he hit him in the eye and he poked
outside what if he hit him in a temple
what if he hit him and chris rock
slipped and hit his head what if he hit
him and chris rock hit him back and they
scuffled on the stage in that moment
there's so many things that could have
happened i didn't the best possible
outcome after that slap is what happened
it's wild chris chris rock deserves an
oscar for the way he behaved after
because he behaved after in a manner
that allows it to escalate i'm ready for
this ready i think i think they walked
backstage they said they said would you
like him removed from the venue that's
what i think and i guarantee that chris
rock said no
um he's gonna win oscar for king richard
uh i'm cool i'm not hurt let's move
forward let's try and i i guarantee you
that there's a lot that's going swept
under the under the rug that chris rock
is a little bit of a hero for this sure
oh yeah
i bet it is all that the academy i was i
was gonna say no matter who saw you're
on the academy didn't address it i
guarantee you i said the same thing you
just said i said because i've seen i've
seen incidents at comedy clubs where two
comics get into it
and the one who's this just happened two
weeks ago with ari yeah i know and what
and and that's the thing when you're on
the receiving end the first thing the
club's gonna do is come to you and say
what do you want us to do right now yeah
and nine times out of ten a comic
especially is gonna go
dude don't make a big [ __ ] just just
yeah man like you know what i mean they
were in tuxedos i know it's wild it's
well i look i said two things i said
today number one folks we talk about it
all the time on this program diet health
uh you know how to get into better shape
how to stay in better shape how to not
fall off the regiment all these things
blah blah blah look it comes down
tonight lifestyle and that's where noom
isn't is is not just a great tool but it
could be a great asset
neum is a psychology-based approach to
getting people on track to eating
healthier it's that simple that's my
favorite part about it because everyone
knows this there's no secret like you
can't you have to change your lifestyle
not your diet diets are fed so noom
works uh basically uh it's not like
restrictive diets or other workout
programs they use basically psychology
to empower you it's a whole different
way of doing it uh and they base it on
scientifically proven principles like
cognitive behavioral therapy or cbt now
this is just very familiar with by the
way are you really i've done that yeah
i've i've found that type of of therapy
to be extremely helpful and the fact
that newm has now folded that and
whatever else into the system that
they've created and the system that you
go in and find that works best for you
is truly incredible to me i think
psychology is such a a a instrumental
piece of your diet and most of what
leads to bad diet has to do with
psychology i i find i find what they're
doing to be fascinating i've used it and
it's really really they also don't
restrict what you can and can't eat yes
they just kind of give you they educate
you so you can make informed choices
they don't beat you up if you mess up
one day that's a whole nother thing
you're not like throwing everything out
the window you just get right back on
track right uh more than 75 this is
telling more than 75 of the users
actually complete the program and more
than sixty percent of the users lose
five percent or more body weight within
four months that's really by week 16
yeah that's really so it's grounded in
science uh
so sign up for your free trial and get
psychology-based support and motivation
to reach your goals at n-o-o-m-dot-com
taste bud that's not buds they do it
they leave off the last ask for savings
that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash taste bud to sign up for
your trial
i'd like to learn a second language i
barely learned my first one
listen thanks to babble the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions it's addictively
fun and easy to learn a new language
they have over 14 languages you could
use it if you're traveling abroad if you
want to connect with your family in a
deeper way or just if you have some free
time they teach bite size lessons you
can do them in 15 minutes they're a lot
of fun they are not done by ai they are
made by actual language experts the
lessons plans are so they are a lot more
intuitive uh and they're scientifically
proven to be effective
babble speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent i think that's great because
sometimes the daunting part of learning
a new language is you feel a little
silly you don't know if you're saying it
correctly right that helps i download an
app for every little thing i'm like oh
look at this word word puzzle game i'll
download the app and they came on board
we talked about this company every week
because
it's just it's just really good they
just you know they stuck with us this
whole time but this is one of the ones
that i actually like like using yes and
i've turned people on to it you know and
it's and now it's not just when i first
did it i was like looking at the
language learning like lessons and stuff
but they've added uh podcast games uh
videos stories and live classes which i
haven't delved into yet i'm excited too
i agree with you this is one of the apps
of all the apps on my phone this is one
of the apps that i do actually like
using too because i have a lot of apps
where i go this is good but then you
don't use it yeah this is a good one
right now you can save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
tastebuds that's babel.com taste buds
for up to 60 off your subscription
babble language for life but but then i
said i go he took that slap like the
joker i go that was insane
that's how the riddler takes he went he
had his hands going back he went
sideways he immediately went back up and
still behind back he went wow wow
that's it he didn't he never touched his
face he wasn't like oh my god he didn't
even he did the police ceremony i have
another that was his reaction he did the
like when you when you hit a guy please
sir may i have another like when you're
like i'm gonna freak out the guy that's
hitting me right now and everyone's
still like this is just a joke that was
that was a fake slap until then until
will smith got like gully in the seat
and he was like keep your wife's name
out you [ __ ] out and then when he
repeated the second time when he really
went in deep and then chris rock was
like i'm doing that will smith
inadvertently just put his wife's mouth
name in everyone's mouth that is all
anyone's doing is making jokes right i
mean inadvertently by being by doing
that and by the way i'm not i'm i'm i'm
in the middle of this
i'm pointing things out he [ __ ] up so
big
for his marriage for his wife for
all of that he
was somebody now it's under a microscope
again like you know what i mean
but it's so exciting
she was like that's right oh she was
like are you [ __ ] serious
and now
it just came out in the news yeah the
academy has condemned will smith's
behavior and now there's there's also a
story saying that will smith might be
yeah get his oscar back
he should not give his oscar back he
should not give his oscar back the work
he did
and and the mistake he made are not
connected they're two separate things
two separate things he should not give
his oscar back it was funny that he came
up and he was like i am a vessel of love
dude i just wanted to hold on he had
such a great opportunity with that
speech and he [ __ ] it up
dude but also by the way side note
denzel
is always amazing and always denzel what
he said
my favorite thing to do on youtube is
watch denzel washington interviews
because he talks like a character in
platitudes yeah yeah it's amazing i saw
in the red carpet once and they go what
do you think what do you think about the
news or whatever and he goes he goes
if you watch the news
if you don't watch news uninformed you
watch news you're missing form so you
can't win but he always talks like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're backstage
he's a sage he's so deep right yeah the
thing he said to him where he's like at
your highest moment that is when the
devil will come for you i was like holy
[ __ ]
it's incredible and then when he's
sitting there when will smith's like
denzel
and they cut the dents out and he's
literally doing that
he's doing like the [ __ ] training
days there i'm like this guy is no joke
so then does denzel yeah his team well
i think he's i don't think he i'm
guessing i don't think he approves of
what will he talk to devil in this
analogy i think so no he's saying your
behavior he's like he's like they this
is when you make the biggest mistakes
when you're out
into the worst temptations i i yeah okay
that's what i think he meant by that i
think that this is when you're going to
be tested we're exactly right right
right okay so so
that's interesting
that's interesting because i'm curious
does this happen i mean something like
this happens
so yes i got the best parking spot in
the world i was on cloud nine i was in
heaven and when i came back someone
parked and they they left their car and
they their bumper was on my bumper they
they parked they hit my car and they
rested their bum and they got out with
their car physically on my car it was
the best spot i ever got and the devil
tested me then and i freaked out i went
in my car it was long ago i got the club
out and i just beat the guy's car with
the clock
that's what i did okay i mean
that's it
did you really do that yeah
the hood i slapped it dark side which i
love buddy i want to get into it
something the unmitigated goal for
someone to hit my car
pop up on top of my hood of my fender
then get out looking and be like i'm
good well the devil's coming after me
because i want to guess it was a woman
because i like i immediately i walked i
i one time this this uh it was a bronco
it was an old school bronco and it
parked so like
so this is so let's say like from here
to here is the curb right and you can
fit uh three cars or two cars it parked
in the middle and i said to my wife a
woman parked that car she said why and
she go and i said because she has no
there's no repercussion for her no one's
gonna whip her ass like like as a man
i've been in confrontations where i
realized hey man i don't want to deal
with all the [ __ ] so let me snug up
here and come here and my wife's like
that is the most sexist thing i've ever
heard you say
she went inside i sat in our adirondacks
and i lit a cigar and i grabbed a drink
and i waited for that car to move i
waited for that car to move they were an
acting class next door at our neighbor
and a woman walked out and i go i go
leanne and then [ __ ] comes out and i
go what did i say and then i just said
her very kindly you know that's for two
spots and she looks around and she goes
it's just one car and i went
oh
the devil's after bird
you looked over your shoulder and that's
how i was in the corner staring at you
and he said he said no honestly whenever
something i'm keep calm
whenever i'm in a tough spot now uh i'll
just think of denzel uh you see when he
was like keep your wife i seen that same
delivery in movies dude
like i was like whoa that's when he gets
like intense in movies that's
interesting that you say that so what
you're saying is that will smith as an
actor can translate genuine emotion that
we witnessed so in a weird way he
deserves that oscar yeah because he does
we watched we watched him paint the
picture right he's gonna look he's
amazing it's so weird when you see
actors do that in real life i was at a i
was
when when bobby kelley
well when bobby kelly and bill burn me
and i believe this is a short this short
film called cheat
and it went it premiered the tribeca
film festival and it got nominated for
best something i forget
and we went to the awards ceremony and
de niro was one of the like presenters
and hosts of the awards smarts were in a
room
a small room with [ __ ] robert de niro
on stage and like
whoever won our i remember whoever won
our category they were calling her name
and she like for some reason wasn't
coming to the stage
and it was like taking a minute and de
niro goes he goes jennifer where are you
and he started and he started doing this
and i was like
holy [ __ ] like it's him that's that's
him like that's when you realize you're
like that's not a thing he made up like
that's what he does when he does that's
who he is come out come out wherever you
are
so [ __ ] crazy like it was like
it was it was weird it's weird but
that's what when like you're saying with
the will thing like when he yelled that
you're like
that's i've heard him like
that's like i am legend wilson
ali
yeah
well can i tell you the one thing that i
can't i can't disconnect from
and this is
bert chrysler if you want to know if
you've listened to millions hours of
podcast and listen to me talk and you go
who is bert
it is chris rock
five seconds after we've been slapped
that is me that is who i am in life i've
been beat up i've been hit probably four
times in my life after jokes really yeah
yeah but when you were just a man you
weren't a comic you were just a man i
got beat up legit in college because i
wrote a song about uh this about all the
guys in our fraternity and one of the
things i said that one of the guys
[ __ ] his girlfriend like meaning like
that he [ __ ] his own girlfriend it was
not any bad and then and i was friends
with a guy and he [ __ ] piledrivered
me gave me a concussion they found me
crying on campus gone right uh same dude
hit me twice by the way freshman year
high school he comes up makes a joke i
laugh and he goes what the [ __ ] you
laughing at and i went you
and he slapped me in the face
and
he walked away
that energy that chris rock had in front
of america i remember having him in
front of like sean hooker camel is there
a play casper i remember having front of
my friends and they're like
dude he's a he's a dick and you're like
yeah
and then you're like i'm just stunned
i'm not here you're like i think i'm
gonna i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go
to my locker and use walk away you're
processing a billion emotional million
emotions and
man
and i know will i know will i'm i'm i'm
knew him i don't know this is why you're
the moderator for the moderator because
you're a comic and you know will and i
know both
i don't know him to be that guy that's
not who i ever saw ever ever ever ever
and i spent a lot of time with the guy i
never saw that guy in him
part of me wonders
if he's this is what hollywood does to
[ __ ] people people throwing out
scientology he they [ __ ] him up so
much
that like and and it's the wards right
like i've never wanted to i may have won
an award but like i've never won
something like that the pressure going
into it and building up and building up
and
and then all of a sudden someone says
the wrong thing
you never know what's going on look you
never know what's going on at home
number one but
that is wild though i guess he's in a
blind he has to be a blind ranger
because you can't calculate
the repercussions of what you're about
to do in those five seconds but like
what did he think would the fallout
would be of that would by the way they
had a video of him just going nuts at
the party dancing and stuff afterwards i
was like how can you even re-reset you
need to go home all you can do all you
can do is escape after that you know
have you ever had a back because i've
had them i've had shows
i've had shows on stage where i have
[ __ ] up royally oh wait let's go tip
for tat
but you know what i mean like i've had
i've had bombs
in clubs on the road where i've like
almost torched any chance of me
returning to the club like the way i
started going after the i don't do it
anymore but there was a time
um and i would start and and after you
do that after you [ __ ] up so bad when
you're under the microscope like that
my only answer was i got to escape now
so i would go to the bar i'd start
drinking with the two people in the
audience that actually liked the show
and i would get blasted the next thing
you know it's like i'm having a good
time it's all good
it's like that's what he did now whether
he drank or not i don't know but clearly
they showed you the in-between like
footage of in-between during the
commercial breaks and like denzel went
up to him and somebody else and then his
publicist
tyler perry a media
[Laughter]
because he's probably just like so
like on a journey i think he's i think
he's and this is the last serious thing
i'll say he didn't apologize and i
tweeted i tweeted about this i think
he's having an emotional breakdown yeah
and i think it is a result of hollywood
and other things it's not a normal life
to live
for any of us it's not a normal life at
my level
it's not a normal life at your level and
we're all at different levels of this
thing it's not a normal life for my
children
it's it's not wrong yeah i talk about
them on stage i've put them in the
public eye
and it is not a normal life for my and
it was wrong to do
we got us our house but you know i like
the house but sure they'll go to college
because of it but they're going to have
to deal with it the rest of their lives
of that that they're not just some
anonymous human being like we got to be
yeah we know your whole family by name
yeah yeah so it's so that's the thing
right so it's like it's not and i think
he's having an emotional breakdown and i
i said on twitter every single person
that stood up and applauded for him in
my opinion
that that's what we are an enabler and
you're also the first people that are
going to throw him under the bus when he
does anything that criticizes or
contradicts your moral hollywood agenda
because that's the thing they're
standing in there with anyone else if
will smith comes out next week and says
something that they that they find
sideways they will cut him off but
you're already going to see it the
academy wants him to well where the [ __ ]
were you guys last night then if that's
where was that where was the apology i
mean like what i i'm so quick i'm sorry
i didn't mean to get on fire no no no no
no no no but i'm so quick to apologize
in real life in real life i apologize
before something happens dude
i i am i had to teach my wife how to
apologize
yeah she didn't i would have my
acceptance speech um my exception speech
would have been this uh yeah let's do
our acceptance speech all right all
right let's do it
then we'll do the battle i'll hear the
battle yeah
jesus sorry sorry how are we at where
are we at
okay that's not too bad okay all right
real quick you know what let's do the
acceptance speeches in the battle
let's just start the battle okay right
yeah but i'm just saying that makes
sense yeah
okay yeah let's start something
all right ready just leave here we go
here we go here we go here we go you
want to do which one you want to do the
nice one the other one
so he uh i feel like we have to just
explain to him real quick yeah please we
used to get very heated and he would
take it home with him and so so i would
tell him don't worry about it
like will smith i go up i slap my wife
so
so he i don't have a wife he's a joke he
started this thing where he started this
thing where we fall right before we'd
fight we we chant look at each other in
the eyes hold each other's hands and say
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you yeah and then we
do that
and it was always less heated so then
after that it started to work so now
last week he goes we gotta flip the
script we gotta get back to fighting
yeah so don't all right don't let's just
do it all right this is this is the one
to get us revved up for the battle okay
all right eddie remember how it goes do
you want to go first with the you do you
have an insult at the ready oh yeah i'm
ready
i'm ready we chant three times and
immediately insult each other to start a
battle okay so
but he has one always waiting
i got one ready for all my friends i'm
like a battle rapper i'm ready to go
okay this is eight miles yeah but it's
totally not so ready yeah uh
ready yeah it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
i gotta be honest with you when it comes
to science i think you're a [ __ ] i
really science yeah what are you talking
about when i talk to you about your
covert worries i think you're stupid
are you insane no no no i'm serious why
am i stupid what covered worries
whenever i express the cover words just
just when we discuss like [ __ ]
we discuss how it works i think you come
off as not as smart as you could how do
you think it works
i don't know as far as you could be i
don't know if you're capable of being
smarter
in my opinion
today full disclosure i was with my
friend all weekend he tested positive
recovery today i go okay he goes what do
you want to do i said i'll come in and
keep my distance from you i said what
the [ __ ] wrong with you
babe i guess i'll just keep my distance
meanwhile he gets on a plane every
weekend meanwhile we're at a private
event at madison square garden up or i'm
sorry at a radio city upstairs packed
room
no masks he wasn't bad night he wasn't
bad
when you called me before i got here and
said my friends who i was with all
weekend tested positive today today's
monday all right guys
hold on you gotta install me back you're
a [ __ ] idiot all right
i had another one
i'm just gonna insult you right on the
heels of this okay you're a [ __ ] that
doesn't understand how
[Music]
will smith i'm keeping as an entertainer
over chris rock i love chris rock you're
one of the great comedians of all time
truly one of the goats uh and i think
chris rock is hilarious but in the
entertainment department in the
department of entertainment titans i'm
keeping will smith and here's why
will smith can be a funny [ __ ]
in movies when he needs to be i think i
could get my last from funny movies a
million funny movies a million funny
movies i love will smith i've seen i
have a sun tattooed on both of my thighs
at the ages of 15 and 21. i have them on
my dice right this second i love his son
i love it god bless will smith he's
given me a lot of joy in my life i like
a lot of his movies if i'm picking one
going forward i don't need such a vast
body of work i don't need more will
smith movies per se one thing i really
want to do is really [ __ ] laugh about
life in general and chris rock is going
to give me that until the day that he's
going to be a working comedian until the
day he dies i can go back and watch one
of the 800 will smith movies already but
i want a new arrow from rock until the
day i die all right sal chris rock is
only as funny as the movies he's been in
but he has not had the hits that will
smith has however will smith is only as
funny as the projects he pick and he has
a horrible track record of picking
projects passed on the matrix passed on
on on so many great projects so now
you're picking someone who hold on chris
rock said yes to that movie where he was
president
[Laughter]
i'm not talking about let's make
something very very clear i'm carving
out chris rock's movies i'm talking
about what chris rock is known for i
said i want his new hour until the day i
die i want to laugh about life
you are right but will smith does not
create his own content he's not writing
his own scripts you're picking a man
with an empty garden technically because
i just made it up
did you really see a shot who are you
denzel
that's incredible all right all right
thanks
so but but you're talking about you're
picking a guy who cannot bear you fruit
because he doesn't know how to harvest
it however we are talking about chris
rock who makes his fruit harvest it and
while not great in every meal i i eat
movies
it is good fruit right okay all right
fair enough fair enough but i'm not one
of these people that thinks okay
like seinfeld always had the take of
like stand-up is hard acting is easy
they give you all the tools for acting
you stand up you got to do it all
yourself there is validity to that
argument but i will tell you something
as a as a moderately employed actor i
find it fascinating when i see somebody
take somebody else's work and bring it
to life and i've seen people do it with
things i've written where where i see
them doing i go jesus christ that's
[ __ ] way better than i had it in my
head i never would have said that hamill
do it with my dad and translate my dad
you're right chris does not have that
ability right but what a will does and
that
but now you're talking the craft of
acting versus the crap to stand up
comedy and you're just talking about in
general will smith
will smith has had a body of work that
is vast that has many hits that i've
liked many of it and those don't go away
we're is about going forward i could
still watch five seasons of a fresh
prince i could still watch everything he
did
i am legend i could watch this bad boys
i can watch it i'm glad you brought up i
am legend because they're making i am
legend too and if they said to you
uh will's not in this one it's gonna
start chris rock instead you wouldn't
care okay i'm sorry i don't mean to [ __ ]
on chris like this
i'm just saying like but but you know
what if
you said will's gonna do a stand-up
special you wouldn't care i don't want
to see that right but we'll try to do
stand-up which is interesting in this
argument we'll focus on stand-up he
opened for dave chappelle at the
hollywood bowl and wanted to be a
stand-up do you think that has anything
to do with that listen he just opened
for chapelle because he thought it was
jada he got the mixtape
i'm wondering like who it's a
bald-headed joke come on people is that
too much
they say they say they say
they say had it been chappelle wouldn't
have slapped him do you think he would
have i do not that was my next i don't
know i don't think i think actually
chris rock somehow was in the sweet spot
of who he would slap if you think of a
lot if you say if it was a woman up
there if it was schumer if it was wanda
sykes if it was dave schmeller it was
the rock if it was anybody else i don't
think he would have gone up i think
something he just [ __ ] looked over
his head he had the [ __ ] terminator
thing go and he goes i can stop this man
i don't see if he has slapped amy
schumer do you realize did the internet
would have shut down i mean it would
appear
it's just that chris rock seems a little
frail and schumer seems like she can
handle herself let's talk now that is
interesting
[Music]
i'm just saying if amy schumer fought
chris rock i think amy schumer just oh
my god
has been an actor a billionaire actor
that has a regimen i wouldn't [ __ ] with
will smith i wouldn't [ __ ]
but i got to be honest but this rock is
110 pounds but this is interesting
what bert brought up is very interesting
thank you that will
opened for dave
and did stan because dave and chris are
very tight they're very tight chris is
at all of dave's shows what's kevin hart
kevin hart's what's he gonna i want to
know his take on this
well well let's let's think about that
for a second because kevin hart we're
about to tour together a big tour
together who should who rock and kevin
hart yeah they're doing a big tour
together i feel like chappelle and kevin
hart would just say
look man you know chipotle's gonna say
something
of course he's gonna do an hour and a
half about it yeah how great
if if they have chappelle hosts the
espys and a transgender swimmer gets up
out of the [ __ ] audience and slaps
the bell
but it's a dude it's like we're not a
dude you know what i mean chris
christopher what up pig shout out to the
pig christian stefano text tweeted vegas
because because i talked to chantal
about what happened last night and he
said that chris rock is trans
the greatest part is to not be either
will smith or chris rock and enjoy all
these tweets like enjoy like it's an
unfortunate situation but how could you
not it's like the greatest train wreck
we've seen in forever question is and
the question is you will pick sides the
the all the america will pick sides when
will does his next thing will he outlive
that guy who slapped everybody this can
you not see him
six minutes later
everybody knows that party saw him
dancing going he's having a good time
everybody's everybody's on chris's side
everybody the the the the twitter the
celebrity reactions on like
like
o'donnell is on chris's side
talk about someone who can take a part
right
tiffany haddish is not on chris's side
really no
that's an interesting thing he said
quote unquote and i'm quoting on quoting
on something i kind of read
jada needs to suck his dick from the
back tonight that's the sexiest thing
i've ever seen is a
quote unquote i'm guessing black man
step stand up for a black woman in
hollywood
yeah there's listen i will i can't argue
that point there that's listen i'm
talking about the good fellow scene all
the time when she goes to tell you the
truth i was turned on when he hands her
the bloody gun after he beats the guy
like of course you were uh
that would be the most amazing thing
ever but look at the hundred ways
doesn't mean i think it's okay he could
have been like he could have stood up
and just said something in that moment
like add a line
oh no yeah yeah you're right okay i'm
sorry he could have waited his little
speech and said i just want to say
something and like eviscerated him or
even just just just really position
himself in a way that made chris rock
look small for doing that again but then
you're also in but then then but also
this too guys will is now also into the
you can't hit a comment
almost now i'm so torn because at the
same time hold on i i have a very
hittable will smith joke i tell a story
about him wanting to [ __ ] me
let me rephrase that to [ __ ] you
yes my dad told me he wanted to [ __ ] me
in the ass and i've told it a lot
thinking will had a sense of humor and
then he'd hear the joke and be able to
listen to the whole thing and understand
your dad told you will wanted to so
not to get all
off
wait you're real dead or martial my real
dad my real dad is this is the movie is
this what mark hamill channeled when my
first when i first met will smith my dad
said to me
he said well it's like hey let's go to
the movies and i was like okay and he's
like i'll meet you at like six at planet
hollywood and i told my dad and my dad
goes like on a date and i go will smith
wanted me to planet hollywood yeah all
right by the way i'm a little nervous to
tell the story now cause i'm afraid i'll
get slapped one day okay now i now know
i've had this joke about will smith
wanting to [ __ ] me in the ass
when's the last time you saw will though
i got a call from him one night he's
probably you know
way back i was pitching a movie
and will called me up and he was like
hey man i heard you're pitching a movie
about a rapper and you didn't reach out
to me what the [ __ ] and i was like i
didn't i didn't know if i could reach
out to you and he's like dude we're
friends man you call me if you have an
idea and i can help you figure it out
and then he's like let me send you a big
disney set me up at disney
full disclosure the pitch had the n word
in it
so if we're gonna [ __ ] be honest with
it and but was cool enough he set me up
at disney i pictured a game last year
yeah i know i just skirt pissed that i
know what it was it was a part of the
pitch the pitch meaning you said it to
the people as you were pitching someone
said in the room who knows oh that's
amazing and so
that's amazing i'm picturing
a bunch of the plaster cast seven dwarf
statues around the board room
because they're trying to make every
border that's disney it's fun in here
[Music]
they almost bought it we got nick cannon
attached nick cannon fell out of it and
then it kind of fell apart but nixon or
but will is a
solid [ __ ] dude that i don't see he's
like the best right you want to know the
greatest guy
he seems amazing we pulled up to abc to
pitch jamie tarsus he goes down and i he
is talking to the ballet guy so in depth
that i said to him how long have you
known this guy and he goes i just met
him i went what he's like yeah yeah try
to treat everyone with kindness that's
who will is that's who he really is
right right so can i just tell you what
i would have done wait can i just tell
you what i mean if i was chris rock i
would have took a [ __ ] dive i would
have fell down and i would have faced
down on the floor and i would have just
stayed there that's what i would have
done just like no no no i would have i
would have took a dive like they do in
like soccer and [ __ ] and i would just
fell you were taking a phone on the
floor and i would have just stayed there
on live television until people had to
come out they had to cut to commercial i
would have just stated they don't know
if you're if you're a conscience enough
you got to do it i would have made it to
a whole to do
it
we all know we all know that just a soft
idea soft pitch no bad pitches no bad
ideas the alopecia challenge
is you have your friend slap you as hard
to get in the face right to raise
awareness for alopecia because that's
her actually that's a good idea yeah
there we go the alope the will smith
challenge hey my name is burke chrysler
and i want to talk i want everyone to
bring awareness to alopecia it's my
buddy joe derosa all right hey man you
want to do it right now are you getting
ready for ti do you want to do it right
now we should do it right now
what do you mean not too hard you just
sit as hard as you can in the face don't
you want people to know about
your [ __ ] hold on hold on wait
i'm way more scared of getting slapped
by you than you are for me
[Laughter]
ready
oh i'm nervous all right i gotta do this
yeah you're doing every side you want
just hang on
take your hat off
i'm saying are you nervous that you're
going to get them square this is a bad
idea that's a really bad idea well a lot
of people suffer from that condition
imagine
dude you know jeff ross people in my
family have suffered from it i've always
wondered because jeff had a beautiful
head of air and then he went bald and
jeff ross tweeted out last night yeah i
saw that i suffered from alopecia and i
went
i didn't know that's what that was and
you know a lot of the dudes at the store
suffered from alopecia a lot of guys
would get it on their face mark norman
would get it on his beard every now and
then i know tons of people even my
family yeah i knew i knew women growing
up
did he know one and two or did he just
see her and her take on it was it's no
big deal
but but also too
this is why i think this is why i think
chris thought it was no big deal i'm
trying to guess how hard the slap would
be well this is why i think chris
thought it was no big deal jada bing it
i'm a fan of jada pinkett she's been
shaving her head for years yeah yeah
pre-alopecia jada
yeah
that was always her style demon knight
one of my favorite horror movies ever
one of jada pinkett's first big roles in
a movie she's got the short hair she's
in her 20s in that thing
but she's gorgeous
weirdest thing about all this is i
didn't register i don't register jada as
not attractive with the shaved head so
that no no i would never make a joke
about her hair because i still find her
sexy same thing with tiffany haddish
like when she shaved her head i just was
like oh you look great like i don't know
i i don't
definitely i'm not woke you know that
but like i'm not i don't look at like
that like those types of things as a
place to make funks i just go whatever
oh i'm fat as [ __ ] you want are you
going to slap me
he's waiting
can i just while you do it can i just
read alopecia statistics millions of
people suffer can you just while you
slap them no no by the way by the way by
the way uh dave dave uh our chef here
says that he thinks it was staged he
thinks it's all the time
but also i was talking to my uh my
business partner paul italia who co-owns
this wonderful place with me he also
said he was like i don't know man i've
really been like going back to the i
think i might have i think it might have
been a a a publicity style which here's
the thing
i thought about this today i don't think
it was stage but think about this
but think about this this is not that
crazy right
but there's nobody think about
entertainment we don't know because
they're actors okay by the way we did a
speech uh when i wrote for the pete home
show tbs one of the monologues we did
are actors or psychopaths that was the
pete
get a talk show on tvs
and i was in motto i was like i think
you mean hbo but he had that yeah and i
was a monologue writer for the tv show
and we would do themed monologues and i
loved them where he would do the x-men
yeah it was [ __ ] great it was really
great
yeah batman yeah
but one of the theme monologues we did
was actors are psychopaths and it was
like it was like i'm sorry you can make
yourself cry on cue what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you know what i mean like
i can't believe anything you say to me i
can make myself crying you don't say it
like myself i can too really easily
i got to get there but i've done it i
did it on camera this year actually but
so think about that so again given that
wait wait here's the whole thing though
here's the whole thing given that given
that fact it's not that crazy i think it
could be said secondly
memes you're an idiot memes i'm not
saying i believe it was stage i'm just
saying you are but here you just names
memes are a huge
memes of the new sex tape they're a huge
form of publicity monday morning me
having coffee
this is the biggest meme
today
and will continue to be the biggest meme
ever saying joe so what
waiting to accept an award and he was
like how do i get a [ __ ] meme
post taste is that crazy are you nuts is
that crazy crazy it's not crazy because
you want to be in control your memes now
the
secret time what you just said you want
to be in control of your memes hang on
hang on so when ari drugged me i did not
release that podcast because i knew i'd
become a meme
whitney cummings called me i shouldn't
say all of this but i'll say it because
i've had it come on
yeah we all have cummings called me give
us a pitch for that movie right you're
never
you're you should never release that
podcast i said why she goes because once
you release it you're not in control of
that story and you become the meme the
shot of you realizing you've been
drugged that becomes me when uh i
realized they're not serving drinks at
you know 2 a.m right and i was like oh i
don't she's and she goes you will be
crying jordan you will be crying jordan
and do not release it and i went and i i
was like [ __ ] i never i'm a meme i am i
have a crying jordan equivalent it's the
worst thing in the world yeah and i
created it and they took off and i know
i i did it on the show it's a meme of me
when i had the flu in 2003. it's a
terrible photo you put on the show
enough and now it's a [ __ ] meme it's
been i mean for like five six years and
it's the worst thing that happened about
the day it became me and people wrote me
like you're a meme you're going to hate
this for the rest of your life what is
your meme i don't think this is my point
if we live in a world where they could
create
a fake
pandemic
could they
[Music]
couldn't they create a fake this is what
i think right i think i think this is
what i think i think i think that
kidding i don't know no matter what jada
said publicly maybe she's having maybe
she was having a harder time with it at
home it's a more sensitive issue than we
know at home because i i have a family
member that has it and for them it's a
tough issue and it's tough on us because
we care so much for them and we don't
want to see them going through anything
like that maybe
she was yeah
that's [ __ ] it
yeah it's the worst picture
it's on it's on every single day
t-shirts college dorm rooms everything
everywhere but i mean you don't want to
be you want to be in control of your
memory
yeah and and but here's the thing too i
am not saying i think it was staged i'm
saying
i'm saying the idea that it could have
been is not that crazy he also ripped it
he looked at her he was i love you and
then he just it's like
you know ball had bad ass you know gi
jane can't wait to see ngi j it wasn't
even the joke isn't even funny i was i i
hate that he ripped it i would i i
visualized a world in which
michelle wolf was backstage he said it
will smith got slapped and she tore a
page out of her joke book with where
that joke was and then just ate it
slowly
i had nothing happened i don't know what
you're talking about
because michelle wrote for the oscars
well i'm sure she did i mean
yeah it's like this never happened does
that mean chappelle is the goat though
because he wouldn't have slapped
chappelle
is that the perception i'll tell you
if he slapped chappelle i think it would
have been a very different outfit he
would have he would have slapped him
hold on
stop
hang on
chappelle's no different than rock
they're they're they're those
outsiders they're both outsiders they're
they're look chappelle does not have
street credibility he's not i mean he's
not he said it admittedly i i've always
co-signed on the fact that i grew up in
the streets but i didn't he comes from i
have two highly educated parents that
were that that chappelle is not like
he's not a tough guy i don't think he's
ever proposed to be a tough guy but
will spend slapping him i can't see a
little i never if you asked me i never
thought chris rockwell couldn't see will
smith
so like i'm not saying that chapelle's
not a badass and he couldn't beat up
will smith oh that's not what i even
mean i don't mean because of uh how they
would handle it
he wouldn't slap tv oh i don't think he
would have stopped so many people okay
so so here's the thing so here's the
thing
this actually leads into my next battle
but we didn't even battle well we're
supposed to do it
by the way is this a is this is just a
two-part battle i don't know i got a lot
more to say
now i want to talk this
let's talk family versus family
okay you're keeping one guy you're
keeping the rest of them and these
aren't you just you just changed the
[ __ ] game
what do you what do i mean family these
are two entertainment families these are
the black baldwins babe you know what
i'm saying like
like
you got jordan rock you got tony
[Music]
which family you keep in entertainment
for me even though i'm team will smith
i'm keeping
tony is my man i'm keeping tony i was on
the [ __ ] tv so i just went
automatically you're just conceding
right now that you're not taking no but
i'm saying if you had to keep one family
in the entertainment business who would
you keep
i think i mean i think the when you
extend to family
you're talking about you're talking
about
perpetuities like meaning like in the
future what will tony and jordan jordan
i think is is i think is the funniest
rock i love george i think jordan's
funny have you ever heard i whip my hair
back and forth
what's that it's willow's song oh my god
the day i taught my daughter isla how to
swing on a swing she she finally figured
it out and it was to the song i with my
head
you knew it i love i love i love tony
i love jordan uh
i apologize you can't have everybody
else now that's no insult to that's no
insult to tony or to anybody i'm not
saying you don't have your own
everybody's got their own career i'm
just saying in theory let's say if when
if the first guy goes away yeah
if alec goes away you don't get william
anymore
you don't get daniel anymore and if
chris goes away you don't you don't get
tony and you don't get jordan let's just
say that let's just throw it into the
art i stand where i stood before because
it's all about for me the comedy that's
what i that's what i want for the rest
of my life i want to be an old man in a
rock or laughing at [ __ ] real quick
yeah versus independence day is what
we're talking about [ __ ] independence
day i hate independent stuff i wouldn't
choose
six degrees of separation that's his
that's his breakout role six degrees of
separation
uh that's not what's on the table uh i
am legendary what goes against bringing
them legendary
hello
hello fresh is america's number one meal
kit you know that because we talk about
it all the time and if you don't know
where have you been people okay hello
fresh you get fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients listen to me
because this is what it's about and you
get seasonal recipes it's delivered
right to your door you skip the grocery
store this is a subscription service
that you could tailor to your needs it
makes home cooking fun easy and
affordable again let me jump in please
do it all right hello fresh i want to
jump in
pimp can edit it from there i want to
jump in he's not getting fresh you're
crazy if you think he's better than that
fit and wholesome recipes for satisfying
and nutritious meals that you could feel
good about they're giving you about what
six recipes per week to choose from
including low calorie
and carb conscious options you can
customize your favorite dishes with
their new hello custom offerings you can
custom that's the one thing you should
call it
for another week you customize it for
you you could skip a week whenever you
want remember i told you i threw hot
sauce in my ramen yeah my hello fresh it
was a miso shrimp and bacon ramen that i
made from hellofresh okay all right uh i
like that you can do that because i have
seen recipes with some of these meal kit
services where you go i like that but i
don't want it what's i don't like salmon
and that into salmon or whatever it is i
like that you can do some swaps on
things here hello fresh is 72 percent
cheaper than a restaurant meal of the
same quality and you can save on average
uh about 65 bucks per month so that's it
it's 50 menu items okay you can pause it
whenever you like and it's they have 30
minute meals and if you're the guy like
me 20 minute meals um yep so go to
hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and use code
tastesbuds16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts you hear this every
week it's an offer that cannot be beat
it's hellofresh.com tastebuds16 use the
code tastebuds16 16 free meals and three
free gifts uh hellofresh america's
number one
meal kit
folks i started a business this year
we're off to a good start we want to
start implementing
some some products some some merch that
we can ship out to the customers and
that's where ship station comes in for
you joey roses that's right and also
ship station is going to come in for us
and the no presh the no presh the no
presh family as we call it chip station
it's alleviating the post office it
handles all your shipping needs wants to
go back to the post office quickly
affordably painlessly online shopping is
not slowing down so if you have a
business that utilizes that you got to
check this out it's trusted by over a
hundred thousand e-commerce sellers
already you could track orders from all
sales sales channels
you can find the best carrier
immediately with the deepest discounted
rates you automate any shipping task in
just a few clicks i love that it finds
you not only the reason to not go to the
post office but the most affordable way
to do the shipping because shipping
costs can often be what thwarts you
from pursuing your personal business and
trust me it is one of those things that
will throw you off course and and and
kind of make you not want to do it it
helps you save time by funneling all of
your orders into one simple interface
you're saving money as i said and you're
saving your sanity so what what
what's fun it funnels all your orders
through the same interface and you can
manage everything across all your
platforms amazon ebay etsy wherever
you're selling it you can manage it
through this platform and you can even
do it on your phone uh so there you go
no more headaches
here
here's where you're gonna get a deal
here all right or you're gonna talk
about the deal you're gonna get yeah
yeah okay ship more and less time with
ships ship station you're gonna use
offer code taste buds to get a free
60-day trial that's two months free no
hassle stress-free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in taste
buds
ship station make ship happen
i'm banger i am legend i am legend is
mine
happiness is [ __ ] brilliant
i am legend is mine if you're gonna talk
action will smith i am legend when his
dog does anything ever ripped you apart
the way when his dog dies i did love the
movie it's amazing yeah but bring the
pain
dead boys [ __ ] the [ __ ] bad boys
trilogy oh you can't let's just say
south african accent for a [ __ ] three
hours
concussion vs tambourine
look at me look at me are you talking
about past
i think wilson scott i told you the
reason i'm choosing rock is because i
can coast on will smith's best it's a
it's a it's a veritable hit [ __ ] hold
on are these two men that have sold to
us
art that we enjoyed in the past and
we're not enjoying currently because
i don't know about curtains currently a
little buddy pouring another one pour
another one
i haven't seen king richard i want to
see it
it's good well and what is it is what
it's about
he's the father of the woman
of the williams yeah he basically how he
like trains the girls to be like great
the willie and now they're tennis
there's no better power in the world
than not knowing anything
about the trailer and i was like this
looks melodramatic but then last night
they showed a clip and i was hooked by
the way let me tell you by the way right
now i'm watching kim williams tonight
all right yeah
king williams whatever it is yeah
what's it called are you gonna
currently watch
king richard watch
king williams currently i'll tell you
what collateral beauty
the a horrible movie pull up the best
horrible movie i've ever seen in my life
which i'm also gonna which i'm awesome
sorry i'm so sorry i hate to interrupt i
hate to interrupt
chris rock got slapped
by will smith for making a joke about
jada's hair when chris rock scroll down
made a movie called bad hair all of
that's a good point that's a good
woman's hair about how they're good
about the about the unfair focus on
black women's hair in america correct
yes yeah how [ __ ] ironic is that
that's very interesting that is so
ironic it's very very interesting i
think people are going to go i might
watch it so chris has chris has
look new jack city a classic banger i i
i i'll never
see
one of my favorites i haven't seen
madagascar he's great in
but dude
here's what's up he's in the worst
lethal weapon do you think chris rock is
going to be
flagged as problematic because
his best friends lose ck and
that group that flags problematic people
i'm louie problematic no i think chris
whiskers rocks take on louie
he said uh he didn't like his haircut
thought he looked like you should be in
gi jane 3.
i am [ __ ] up
but here's the thing i think i think you
could i think you could compare
if you're going to compare chris's
stand-up specials i think what we got to
put we haven't even gotten into this yet
oh
guys this is a two-parter
we should get some cocaine
and really dig into this i'll settle for
this guy
this is a two-part app
because
i'm about to hit i'm about to hit you
with something that's going to knock you
sideways i love when you do this all
right you want to can i get a miller
light from one of the camera people even
touch my beard my beard
i need another highlight for me and a
highlight i'll take a highlight thank
you so much
get one for yourself
um
i'm gonna hit you with something we
didn't even touch him
oh boy this is good this is going to by
the way
by the way i keep waiting for it i look
forward to doing all of us now being on
skanks tonight
i already knew when i told you that he
was going i might be going but i had too
much work because of this
the will smith slap challenge to raise
awareness of alopecia how much do you
think
i'm just kidding i didn't do it i was
just kidding but that's what chris rock
should have done no how much do you
think lewis is going to love the [ __ ]
piece of challenge because so wait time
to get started skank starts 9 30 not
eight unless the chris takes buddy they
move
it ends late
wait i can't have a work man no no it
starts at eight it starts at eight you
it starts at eight stand
it starts at eight what work do you have
to do what dude you are in jobs cruise
control it's called impractical jokers
is the biggest show on tv cruise control
baby
harassing people
this is this is the work yesterday you
gotta be up early years ago
is it funnier if murr wears the gorilla
mask
you put some cheap beer into your
[ __ ] gullet and you become this guy
oh
yeah yeah bring it [ __ ] bring it
rig it you
submit a packet i'll [ __ ] piss on it
you like it do you like it yeah this is
beautiful actually really okay
listen right now yeah right
28. who are you no what are we doing
right i thought we i thought we talked
about the other day and i went i was
like having a connection over something
i was 12. all right what are you guys
doing here what are you doing
all right all right let's do that
by the way i have a packet i have a
packet ready for the show
you want it yes send me a packet yeah
[Laughter]
it's at the prank store down the street
there's a there's a box of fake dog [ __ ]
minimize it and while you're at it make
me a [ __ ] bologna cheese sandwich
fair enough you son of a [ __ ]
oh wow you two are good yeah yeah
wait this is okay
i bought some bologna i have an idea for
a prank can i borrow some [ __ ]
bologna i get a good balloon
rubber put rubber bologna and bread it's
a hilarious prank
we're gonna schmuck you know it's me
we'll do some counting time he might not
be able to come because he has to
[ __ ] he has to button
he's a professional comedian who has to
bartend tonight
he can't come
you can't come listen i want i listen
let's just hop around the cloud tonight
and have a great time joe i know you got
to do stations here in case somebody
wants a sandwich
listen i never said i never said i
didn't stink i never said i didn't stink
just use stink too
joe stay here the boxing that might need
to get singles tonight
there we go there we go that's the
[ __ ] juice i like come on this is a
great place
baby this is a great [ __ ] podcast
wait wait what were you gonna say i'm
just gonna change the game you texted me
today and told me he wants to start a
aftertaste on all the bad tastes you
have
wait we should do that we should do a
talking a talking dead thing called
aftertaste where we just talk about what
just happened on the episode
it would be insane
take a picture of the [ __ ] logos
let's go
[Laughter]
all right wait i'm dying this is what i
was gonna say this is what i was gonna
say
and i haven't even introduced this yet
if you're gonna say rocks specials fair
argument very fair are classics
we gotta put them up against will's
rap songs
i think i can beat mike tyson girls in
the world nothing about charlotte
nightmare on
on my stream brand new funk i mean
that's gotta come with
oh my it summer time by the way those
are all amazing songs but let's be
honest they're all sampled from even
more amazing songs no no no no no no no
no no no no no
let me ask you this let me just simple
question let me ask you this would you
rather
go to a comedy thing right
and see
what's the thing chris's new hour
which i would like to see yeah obviously
but would you rather go do a thing and
go i'm going to see chris rockstar or
i'm going to go see will smith and dj
jazzy jeff and they're going to hit me
with all the bangers over there where
are you no but don't change the [ __ ]
no we're saying what we're saying
okay well now here's the deal
we can't do that because we're talking
about a piece of art that's been out
that we have connections to on our
memories with what if you're asking me
this which is kind of like a versus
battle if you're gonna say will smith
will play the banger but then explain to
you how he wrote it and chris rock as
comics will
talk about black people versus n-words
and then explain how he got there
i'm sitting in chris rock's [ __ ]
thing but what i'm saying
as an artist i'm more interested in
chris rock's process than i am sure
okay that's fair enough but what i'm
saying is this
you're saying we get to keep one
entertainer entertainer for the rest of
time
two years from now
chris rock is over here with his new
hour
and across the street is will smith
doing a live concert where you know
he's gonna hit you with the heat he
hasn't toured and you're just drowning
up now no that's not true he tours all
the time no he doesn't yeah no no
you've got it you've got a great you've
got a great argument however we've got
to make it even right so in two years
time we get chris rock's new special the
harmonica hour versus
versus now i'm just busting balls i hope
he can take it yeah i know he can take a
joke so
chris rock's new special and kris knock
rock's new movie just like which i
thought was great movie do you think i'm
going to pass top five top five
no way or
the didgeridoo minute
or uh
will smith's new album oh let's be real
new album new album and and
his new movie
and you gotta remember he doesn't know
the best track record bigger than the
best projects well neither was chris
with movies
chris writes here's my point here's my
point you got to talk what a live
performance is for chris rock versus
what a live performance is for will
smith all right live performance concert
from chris rock
do i want to see rock in the round or do
i want to see will smith sing his songs
you're telling me you don't want to see
will smith doing jiggy with it
miami
what i said was i have enough things i
love in will smith's past that i can use
that to coast forever i don't need more
will smith he's done it all he's a
triple threat
all forgetting that in chris rock's new
hour
going to have 15 minutes
the first thing i thought about the
first thing i thought about was like
well i can't wait to see this i can't
wait that's okay should we go to the
phones
yeah
let's do our acceptance speeches oh yeah
accept the speeches and then we'll just
we'll just we're at an hour and ten we
still have to do the next battle i know
so we'll just do our accepted speeches
and then we'll just we won't read
this will be one where we don't read
tweets we'll just go to the vote we'll
just see what who won
all right i disagree but all right
well you were saying that you wanted to
wrap it up i was trying to sort of help
you
i'm trying to get into character
so who are he we're will smith
chris rocky made a joke about jada that
we took it wrong we've approached chris
rock we've slapped him denzel's talking
to us battle wasn't supposed to be about
no no but no but we're just giving our
acceptance speech i need you in
character okay all right
and then and i want you to give the
acceptance speech he should have given
okay
but you got to remember the one he
started with
the he's accepting an oscar for king
richard who was a very protective family
member all right you want me to start it
off so that you guys can please okay you
seem to have a handle on it i might just
i think my head's around where he should
have gone
are you in trouble i'm trying to get
right
okay
i
this is what the pitch was like
yeah jesus christ
i'm glad the show didn't go
hear the movie it was get him to the
greek i was pitching together with the
greek and there was a brilliant scene in
washington dc it was about but it was
about a rapper and a young assistant
instead of you know the way it turned
out to be and it was wait you mean the
literal movie the movie i pissed was get
him to the greek it was i was pitching
get him with the greek you mean it was
similar to it it was identical it was
identical but it was a young hip-hop
artist and a young uh white intern and
then my intern had to get him he had a
fear of flying and he had to get him
from uh new york to miami and so
throughout the way we went through the
south and he ran into family members he
got his ass whipped at a party the
intern got his ass up to party took
drugs it was like [ __ ] it was get him to
the creek
but with diversity and hollywood passed
back before progressing this okay here
we go
all right
do you think they didn't take the movie
because you stole another movie
do you think that might have something
to do with this i've been just seven
years before to get him to the green let
me bring him oh it was before getting
him to the ground i didn't mention after
the way you said it you know it was get
him to the creek except for the wrath i
was like i just copied together
it's about a family they're all italian
right one's the gods
let's go the tenors i look and i'm
sitting in the room going there's
another movie just like this that did
really well why wouldn't you like my
movie that's what i thought you were
saying no no okay okay seven years
before we get into the greek i pitched
this movie called c train
okay let me bring you up right now who
am i am i elizabeth ellie who am i who
brought up will eliza mannelli brought
up
she did
was she there i already i thought it was
true i mean she doesn't know she was no
no
no no it's not live
and i i really i actually i was very
touched by the lies of vanelli momentum
mentally okay uh she was a little out of
sorts
but it was it was the door it was like
endearing i love elizabeth yeah she's a
beast no i heard slappy wilson brought
him up
all right you're on stage and the winner
is will smith will smith
king williams
and i just want to say will you've let
yourself go but uh
first off
this will be my speech
i want to first i want oh wow i can get
into it i could cry in a second i want
to thank the academy
i want to thank
uh everyone in this room and i want to
apologize
my behavior tonight
was
not exemplary of the man i want to be
this movie that i did king richard he
was a protective man about his family at
times me and my family have have shared
a lot sometimes too much
and i think at times people forget i'm a
real person
and today
as a real person i made a big mistake i
would like to make an apology
to chris rock
and all i would like to do
in this moment of gratitude is thank my
beautiful wife jada for being with me
and delivering me two gorgeous kids and
being the mother of my first son you are
a great partner i love you i think
you're absolutely beautiful
and and i hope i can grow
and be the man you deserve
come on
you know maybe i'm just like uh
i would have been up there like
i was wrong
i was wrong it's weird in this room
right now it's been waiting for the last
30 minutes
and i don't know what happened and this
is going to go down in the books and
here i am telling you i was wrong right
after you know i will let him bring him
out
and let him slap me right now
tit for tat on national television and
when it's done i'd like to thank the
producers my team at caa and everybody
and of course jada and that's what i
would have done i just would have been
like i [ __ ] up i would have made it
into a thing and i would have squashed
it right there how great would have been
if he had taken denzel's words and made
them his own and they just
yeah he's like you know i've always
thought when you're at your highest
that's when the devil comes and gets you
and then cut to denzel
yeah
which by by the way the devil wasn't
watching he wasn't hanging out yeah if
he just started quoting like denzel
movies he's like
uh denzel told me
that the equalizer had to be
like i didn't say that well there's one
of my movies
denzel said he had the most slappable
face in hollywood and i was like
all right here's my speech ready or you
can just go up and like who else wants
to get slapped
come on i'm gonna break up your dental
mic
the uh all right ready
oh jesus yeah charge him for a new one
never forget that mike
because by the way this is what he's
used to is that he can go around doing
whatever he wants because he's a big
[ __ ] celebrity
and he never has to pay for any of it
right make him pay for that mic right
right right
you're a will smith you can do whatever
you want no it's not just comedy fans
that don't like him it's the lay person
as well yeah it's most people who we
come across
my gift is that i know how to make
people not like me here this is where i
switch
to spend my speech look at this look at
look what you just did look because i'm
not dropping it again
all right if this one's now destroyed
i go uh
there you go i know earlier tonight
thank you everybody for uh giving me the
award i know earlier tonight i did
something that a lot of you think was
very crazy
i can't argue with it it was very crazy
and i'd just like to say
that if i could go back to that moment
i'd do it all over again [ __ ] you chris
rock you bitch-ass [ __ ]
and [ __ ] all y'all
[ __ ] everyone in this room
baby if you're gonna do it do it if
you're gonna do it do it you gotta
double down that's what i would do if
you just went up grabbed the mic and
goes
i'm the bad guy
and then billy eilis
dude what if he went up and he goes she
goes denzel said to me
i'm the bag and he starts doing scarface
i was like i didn't that's scarface her
uterus is polluted
oh my god that would have been amazing
yeah and the only thing hold up the only
thing talking to me the only thing i
would add to my speech
is i would have went up with coke
clearly crusted all over my nose and it
just started going in and i mean could
anything have been greater if he walked
up and he hit that [ __ ] white powder
on his nose oh that would if he just was
like guys there was a fly next to his
face i was trying to never mind
i guess parents aren't the only people
who don't understand
that's what i would have said yeah you
know what else doesn't understand chris
rock because i will
whip your [ __ ] ass understand that
chris god i just hope that one day when
i get hit
would have been i do it as gracefully
and simply as chris rock did so there's
three people that gave him his oscar
what if he's just one of them slapped
all of them
actually wait wait wait wait wait i want
to change my speech
okay i love it i love it i go up and go
i wish mine was more funny but i'm going
to take without the hearing edition of
this podcast
like guys
what can i say chris come up here you
can let me in the face as hard as you
want right now and that's it i'd be like
god before i can take the word like i
just [ __ ] said that did you just say
that you are a piece of garbage did you
just you're a hot pile where you did gob
yeah i just said it that was my speech
you don't even listen to me
you have the the stones to talk to me
about accidentally dropping a mic and
you didn't say
yes
such a real thing do you think people
will enjoy me on this podcast or dislike
me vote
v how many votes are we at
give us a reload and then uh i feel like
i'm going to get laced on this because
i'm going to get pummeled because
chris i mean
he's i think you're going to win what's
with that's broader appeal i think i
said disregard what happened in the
polls
i don't think nobody's going to do that
yeah i think i'm going to because i mean
i'm starting with comedy here not
everyone's going to do that so we have
11
491 votes okay um and do you want me to
say i'm gonna roll these
[Music]
yes go ahead i'm looking at my instagram
stories to try to find out where we're
at oh did you put a poll on i'm going to
hold on
he's clicking will smith by the way i
can see which might mean smith won wow
the poll was worded taste buddies not
referencing the awards please disregard
them you can only choose one to
entertain you for the rest of your life
who do you choose
chris rock 62.231 i thought you had me i
swear to god i i i would have put my eye
on chris rock really 82
on my instagram for who chris rock yeah
wow
you can't divorce yourself from what
just happened well i asked not you i'm
saying i feel like nobody's gonna be
able to it doesn't matter
we're talking about their careers
with almost encyclopedic knowledge right
now the average person isn't going
that's what's happening
more about will smith you know
chris rock told a joke and he got
slapped for you you shouldn't slap a
comedian and by the way you should not
slap a comedian
all right so here we go hold on hold on
a piece of challenge here we
go wait you can start from wait let's
wait
i don't want to do this
all right how are you doing to me
[Music]
he's not even remembering sentences from
moments before
and by the
[Music]
mouth no i can't i can't i'd rather you
have you slapped me than use me slap you
seriously i can't i can't no no how
about this how about this
you just bit
[Music]
wait wait wait wait right before you
wait
right
right before you do it say keep my
wife's name out your [ __ ] mouth
take that [ __ ] ring off
i would rather you hit me first let me
hit you i understand
but i can't get it up unless you hit me
first
no hit me first hit me first i'll feel
better about it
show me how hard i should hit him i will
say something if you hit him too soft
it's going to be an underwhelming moment
i would say i would say go hard and just
wish you could take it back
and then and and make it the moment it
needs to be then going sexually and not
and there's a speech crazy you're crying
uncontrollably after
and then it'll make sense wait wait do
you realize this is the antithesis of
comedy you're slapping someone because
it gets real all of a sudden it gets
real that's what's ruined that's what
ruined everything can i be honest with
you i want you to slap him so bad and
then and then i'm gonna stop you and
you've gotta tell a joke about
documentary films you get slapped what
is that i wanna see you guys
everybody thinks he's a nice guy
all right hold on hold on hold on give
me a shot too
nobody does but honestly just just you
know
i'll give you a hint you know what we
need to do is slap him envision his face
as joe derosas
[Music]
all right ready
no
you need courage to hit me
come on
because i'm afraid it's going to change
everything
we're having so much fun and if i don't
hit you i almost passed out anybody
time but announce the challenge uh
cheers same time ready ready here we go
ready no no we're going first
we go the same time no no here we go
here we go hold on i want you to go
first you're going first okay here we go
folks do you want to say what this is a
challenge so it brings awareness
this is the alopecia challenge it brings
awareness to alopecia we challenge you
by the way i just want to clear it we're
not making a mockery of that no we're
not you guys are going to stop each
other that's kind of funny but you know
the alopecia part no we're not making a
mockery of it at all we'll make a
donation
no seriously you're making a donation i
will i just bought a [ __ ] watch
[Laughter]
we're making a donation we're not making
a mockery this is the alopecia challenge
this is to raise awareness about
alopecia
i can't wait to make a donation we are
taking an unfortunate incident and
turning it into a positive thing to
raise awareness for this terrible
condition that's what it is honestly
honestly that's what it is
it is for me
you guys are acting like you're [ __ ]
tyson and holyfield
god
[Applause]
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
i was not expecting
announce the documentary winner
that's how hard he hit him right wow
dude
he has so much respect
hold on a second
hold on you have so much clean slack you
have so much respect for him
[Music]
all right
dude that was wild okay i got uh just
fingers that was crazy that was great
that was one of the greatest moments of
my life that was good that was really
good
that was good that was a good slam
did we record that
i'm joking i'm joking
dude
show me oh my god
oh wow it is red you see it is oh that's
the well that's what when you stop a
black guy you can't sleep
poor chris rock fell victim to the fact
that you couldn't see the slap on his
face guys i honestly i think the
alopecia challenge has legs i really do
i think we just created something yeah
or we bandwagoned it
i think it's like sweating right now i
am
[Laughter]
make sure to get your tickets out what
date you got coming
evansville indianapolis
yeah i know you're the [ __ ] routing
louisville evansville okc tulsa new york
city may 14th uh los angeles makes 26.
i'm at the greek may 5th cinco de mayo
come see me yeah
the uh
i'm in houston for the coming ticket
festival in may i mean i'm at the creek
and cave in may four shows uh and uh and
under the punchline in july uh in san
francisco
there you go
come to joey rogers
come to joey rose
you're an l.a guy this is if this is
your crowd may 22nd at the wilson guys
and may 21st in san diego that's what i
need yeah 22nd at the wilton go ahead
this has been the [ __ ] greatest
podcast i've ever done been the greatest
doesn't he have to slap you now i
thought we were done
what do we have your time watch he
doesn't know where he is
tonight we go i got news for you we go
another we got another 10-15 minutes we
got a two-parter on our hands which we
should just do
and and we don't do the other one at all
okay let's cut it all right let's make a
buddy let's pick a
yeah all right let's make up all right
you know yeah we want sandwiches all
right we'll be back with the next
episode i'm sorry well go ahead i gotta
sign off oh yeah i'm sorry we'll be back
next episode with uh oh
bloody mary versus mimosas
the documentary for filming sandwiches
anyway we'll be right back uh
i still love you
babe you too
i love everyone i love everyone
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds